nosotros somos los Héroes de la patria
señores
gustados frente al congreso de Guatemala
los veteranos militares exigen que se
les retribuya con dinero la guerra que
pelearon durante 36 años y que dejó más
de 200.000 Muertos Pues fíjate que el
señor presidente nos ofreció pagarlos
nuestros derechos de que del conflicto
armado interno pero hasta este día él no
nos ha puesto la cara
al no contar con una pensión los
veteranos de guerras se aferraron a la
promesa política del presidente
Alejandro yamatey de recibir un Bono
económico un proyecto de ley que lleva
tres años sin avanzar en el congreso
entonces queremos que se nos aprueba los
derechos que estamos peleando
Arcadio de Jesús oliva Pérez es uno de
los 98.000 ex militares guatemaltecos
que exige la indemnización de más de 15
mil dólares
actualmente vive en una aldea rural de
Guatemala donde aún conserva las fotos
de cuando era un joven que reclutaron a
la fuerza para pelear en el monte los
años más cruentos de la guerra
en la guerra si no mata uno lo matan a
uno verdad Pero de que me defendí en
ciertos momentos con mi arma si lo hice
otro de los recuerdos que conserva son
las botas de patrullero
el ponerme ahora las botas Pues para mí
no es que se diga una una alegría un
orgullo porque la verdad
los beneficiados de la defensa de la
para de la patria
eran los cabezones del ejército
con 58 años Arcadio tiene cuatro hijos
nueve nietos un bisnieto y ninguna
pensión a la vista ala Qué rico
motivos para luchar por un Bono de
guerra que posiblemente no va a obtener
y que ante la Carta Magna de Guatemala
es inconstitucional